[Music]
I can't leave now yet I'm stuck though I
let myself down how to let go cuz I
can't maintain on my own now and I can't
look back wish I could thr and I don't
really want to say this part I'm afraid
of what you P me for even no it now it
wasn't my fault I can never see get that
far these
voices bar lights
perers the worst Parts
over but I'm still
so cuz now my house feel like a cheap
hotel room if I wake up won't be until
no hard shap Chang on the dirty carpet
everywhere I never got a chance to see
see what's out there I can make dos on a
popcorn ceiling waiting on light to come
and find me before I do spending my time
in the workshop obsessing on these songs
till they up drop I'll keep you
entertained with my dark thoughts
100,000 streams for a soft spot and I
don't want to live this part I'm afraid
of what you play me for even though I
know it wasn't your fault
I can never seem to get that far these
voices bares but good the parts
over but I'm still
so CU now my house feel like a cheap
hotel room if I wake up won't be until
noon heart shake stays on the dirty
carpet
everywhere I never got a chance to see
what's out there I can NE dos on a
popcorn ceiling W I like to come and
find me before I do I don't really want
to say this part I'm afraid of what
you'll P me for even though I know it
wasn't my fa I can never seem to get
that far all these
B bars lines
perus the worst part's over but I'm
still so
cuz now my house feel like a cheap hotel
room if I wake up won't be until noon H
Shake St on the dirty carpet
everywhere I never got a chance to see
what's out there I canect to popcorn
ceiling W on light to come and fin me
before
I
you are a
freak what I'm serious you're a freak do
do you want to be normal do you want to
be just like everyone
[Music]
else
hey friends I hope you dug that video
and I hope you dug the great camera work
because this man right here my friend
Mufasa was responsible for
it uh muasa where can they find you on
social media you can find me at fom Mona
on Instagram YouTube as well as Facebook
sometimes outstanding well thanks again
for your help bro of course man Co peace
friends hey friends I hope you enjoyed
that really fun dance video at uh a park
that is just up the street for me in
Silver Spring Maryland um real quickly I
wanted put out a huge thank you to uh
Ultra poy for sponsoring this video and
making it possible for me to get out and
explore my flow in the DMV that's uh DC
Maryland Virginia for those of you that
don't live in the area which uh I'm been
rapidly discovering nobody outside of
this area knows that that's a thing
anyhow uh if you'd like to grab a set of
those orb poy Pros that I was using in
this video uh you can do so and get a
discount by using the promo code brex
factory with a zero instead of an O at
checkout over at ultra.com
thank you once again to ultra PO for
sponsoring this video and sponsoring my
flow and supporting me as an artist
huzzah uh speaking of thank yous I owe a
thank you to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyroar
light toys spinballs and Ultra poy for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel That is Becca Becken thank
you so much for supporting my channel my
work and my
mission uh finally uh videos on my
channel would not be possible were it
not for the awesome patreon supporters
that I have that help make them happen
uh in particular I would like to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are on
screen right now if you would like to
check out some more of my flow videos I
will include a link to a playlist of
those down in the description uh as well
as a link to my patreon if you'd like to
sign up to support the channel which I
personally would really appreciate
thanks so much for watching make sure to
get out and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon peace